[Musique]
bienvenue à tous ravis de vous retrouver
qui dit rentrée dit nouveauté cette
année ça se confirme le plateau de
saclay accueille deux grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs de plus et pas n'importe
lesquels centrale supélec que vous voyez
juste derrière moi lnc paristech paris
saclay tv vous y emmène nous avons
rendez vous avec les chefs
d'établissements et pour accueillir ces
nouveaux étudiants votre territoire sort
le grand jeu
gros plan sur ces rames 10-city une
résidence qui comprend un millier de
logements
d'autres espaces de vie secret comme le
jardin argenté me vous en avions parlé
il est presque prêt il sera ouvert
complètement au public cet hiver enfin
notre agenda
ce sera la fin de cette émission
nous voici donc dans l'une des plus
grandes écoles françaises l'une des plus
grandes écoles d'ingénieurs centrale
supélec qui a pris ses quartiers ici à
gif-sur-yvette 73 mille mètres carrés
qui vont accueillir près de 4000
étudiants certains sont déjà là sont
déjà en cours et je me trouve donc avec
le directeur général de centrale supélec
r&d bio serre bonjour bonjour donc vous
voici donc dans ce bâtiment hors norme
je disais signé par un très grand
architecte rem koolhaas alors comment
s'est passée cette rentrée est ce que ce
bâtiment correspond à ce que vous
attendiez
la rentrée se passe très très bien elle
suscite de la part de nos personnels et
nos élèves beaucoup d'enthousiasmé parce
que nous sommes dans la modernité dans
l'ouverture et dans le partage et ce
bâtiment que nous découvrons avec lequel
nous apprenons à vivre remplit tous nos
espoirs c'est un rêve qui se réalise
parce que c'est évidemment un lieu de
travail et un lieu d'étude mais c'est
surtout un lieu de vie un lieu de
partage un lieu de création et les
rencontres que qui se passe
quotidiennement entre les élèves les
personnels les intervenants extérieurs
les enseignants sont extrêmement riches
donc c'est un rêve qui se réalise pour
nous oui ça corresponde avoir à l'esprit
de centrale supélec tout à fait le
bâtiment est structurée sur ce que nous
souhaitons transféré à nos élèves à nos
étudiants
il est structuré en quatre grandes zones
enfin quatre grands univers pour
reprendre le vocabulaire des architectes
celui évidemment de la science et de la
technique
parce que nous sommes des engins
mais aussi celui de l'entreprise parce
que la plupart de nos diplômés vont être
des acteurs importants d'entreprise
celui dit du monde parce que ils devront
vivre dans un monde ouvert et puis enfin
celui de l'homme puisque dans notre
projet est la raison humaine est
extrêmement importante
rien ne se fait sans la confiance et le
développement des hommes et donc le
bâtiment des deux bâtiments nouveaux de
chaque campus sont structurés sur ces
quatre univers c'était important de
venir vous installer ici sur le plateau
de saclay pourquoi les deux raisons
c'est la concrétisation de la fusion
entre centrale et supélec d'une part et
le fait que nous avons toujours voulu
être au coeur de ce plateau de saclay
qui est un des grands projets français
et qui sera je le répète le premier
cluster scientifique européen et puis il
ya les transports qui sont vous êtes
membre connectez vous
là encore on est maintenant de plus en
plus connecté avec la ville il va y
avoir également des lieux de vie qui
vont être de l'autre côté du côté du
carré des sciences et évidemment ce
qu'on fait que plus c'est la mixité ses
sept principes de mixité c'était
d'ailleurs une des sept valeurs que nous
avions donné vos architectes dans la
construction c'était l'ouverture et la
mixité et je souhaite qu'effectivement
quand tu rates ans à l'école des
spectacles des conférences moi je
souhaite que l'habitant notamment
djibril et plus généralement de la
région viennent soient accueillis puisse
y participer
ce qui n'était pas très facile dans nos
campus historique donc beaucoup de
projets à venir
qu'est ce qu'on peut vous souhaiter pour
cette rentrée 2010 est qu' a priori se
passe plutôt bien
est-ce que vous pouvez nous me souhaiter
c'est que c'est que les personnels et
les
les élèves envahissent campus deal en
face leur campus
et ça je l'aurais dit d'ailleurs dans
les ligues discours que je prononce lors
de la rentrée des classes on y trouver
vos lieux de vie fait en un lieu de vie
vive et danser dans ces bâtiments
trouver des endroits où vous avez envie
de travailler de partager dans ce
bâtiment et dans le m l'autre bâtiment
il ya beaucoup d' espaces qui sont
réservées pour les associations
étudiantes
donc ce que vous pouvez nous souhaiter
c'est que les usages comme on dit
maintenant se développe et que ça
devienne le mieux commun voilà c'est ça
vous fait vous souhaitez mieux et bien
vous souhaite tout ce qui est meilleur
pour centrale supélec qui vient
s'installer à gif sur yvette
donc merci à hervé hauvieux sert d'avoir
accordé quelques minutes de votre temps
de l'homme maintenant partir à la nhtsa
de paristech autres grandes écoles
d'ingénieurs qui s'est installée ici sur
le territoire à l'est plusieurs mètres
comme promis voici arrivé à l'insep
paris tech qui fait partie du jeu nes le
groupe des écoles nationales d'économie
et statistiques que pour en savoir plus
je me trouve avec le directeur général
du gène s lee kun hee ho bonjour bonjour
alors expliquez nous qu'est-ce que le
geste mais le gênait c'est un ensemble
d'écoles et de centres de recherche avec
d'autres organismes son objectif c'est
de fournir une prestation complète de
formation initiale continue de
rechercher aussi d'ingénierie aux
entreprises et aux administrations
alors là vous faites votre rentrée sur
le territoire sur le plateau de saclay
pourquoi ce choix
d'ici quelques années ce plateau savate
15% de la recherche française
c'est un lieu extraordinaire pour
développer la pluridisciplinarité pour
développer les synergies pour travailler
ensemble mais pour être visible au
niveau international
dans le projet que nous avons c'est
vraiment de développer un projet
universitaire mon sens de marier la
formation et la recherche
c'est déjà quelque chose que nous avons
l'habitude de faire dans les écoles dans
la nhtsa et paristech dans l'aisne
saillie qui traîne mais
sur le plateau nous allons avoir la
possibilité de développer beaucoup plus
cette synergie
donc ça c'est vraiment le coeur du
projet l'idée c'est de faire rentrer en
plus et un grand campus
c'est un endroit où on étudie où il ya
des salles de cours c'est un endroit où
on produit de la recherche mais c'est
dans un endroit où on vit est en fait
vous savez bien on dit toujours que les
grandes découvertes se font dans les
cafétérias elles se font dans les lieux
de vie et ça va être une réussite ici si
les gens vivent ici ils s'y sentent bien
alors qu'est ce qu'on peut vous
souhaiter pour cette rentrée 2010 est
rentré inédite à un nouveau lieu
nouveaux territoires
bien que les gens qui s'installent dans
ce bâtiment continue à être aussi
content qu'ils le sont depuis le 15
jours qu'ils ont commencé à arriver et
que nos relations avec tous les
établissements autour avec les grandes
écoles et les universités continuent
d'être fructueuse elle soit plus en plus
merci merci afideo d'avoir gardé
quelques merci à vous pour paris saclay
tv et on va en savoir plus maintenant
sur lindsay paristech puisque nous
allons rencontrer son directeur général
qui lui aussi est à nouveau au pouvoir
absolu même plus récent que le bâtiment
en voix
donc nous voici dans la bibliothèque de
l'ensae paristech un lieu emblématique
avec le tout nouveau directeur donc de
cette école pierre bis courte bonjour
donc vous êtes nouveau effectivement
puisque nouveau en tant que directeur
mais vous êtes en terrain connu puisque
vous êtes à un ancien élève de cette
école
tout à fait j'en étais aussi le
directeur des études entre 2005 et 2010
je connais un peu l'école vous
connaissez bien à l'école alors
justement expliqué nous qu'est-ce qu'on
qu'est ce que nous proposait aux
étudiants de l'aisne faye paristech
alors linceul paristech est une école
d'ingénieurs en premier lieu une école
d'ingénieurs originale dans le paysage
des écoles d'ingénieurs originale de
deux points de vue essentiellement
d'abord par la diversité des
recrutements
donc il faut avoir en tête 7 les
origines différentes et des élèves qu'on
recrute alors sur concours des
préparations aux écoles de commerce
option mathématiques les préparations
aux écoles normales supérieures donc les
campbell et puis des élèves qui viennent
de prépa mathématiques ce qu'on appelle
les taupins qui constitue la plus grande
partie des élèves de première année mais
on a ce mélange intéressant entre
économistes matheux qui vont finalement
première année se rejoindre et former
une
une promotion ou on va essayer de tirer
un peu le meilleur ddd culture quand
acquise de ses élèves avant d'arriver
chez nous alors il se retrouve ici dans
un lieu flambant neuf
est-ce que c'est totalement cohérent de
se retrouver ici sur le territoire sur
le plateau de saclay alors que
l'installation à palaiseau c'est un
projet qui remonte à envahir une dizaine
d'années on en parlait déjà quand
j'étais directeur des études dans la
deuxième moitié des années
il c'est un projet qui qui fait sens de
plusieurs points de vue on est une école
d'ingénieurs on a des relations étroites
avec l'école polytechnique
historiquement puisque la série est une
école d'application de l'école
polytechnique mais aussi avec toute une
série d'écoles d'ingénieurs qui sont
regroupés au sein du réseau paristech
il ya quelques années et qui
progressivement vont s'installer
également sur le plateau de saclay dont
je pense à l'estaque et sur le plateau
depuis 2005 12
je pense à télécom paristech qui va
s'installer dans deux ans je pense à
l'agroparistech qui va s'installer
encore un peu plus tard on à ces
échanges dans le cadre évidemment de
parcours d'étudiant notamment de
parcours de double diplôme avec toutes
ses écoles on a aussi des master en
commun
voilà l'idée étant de développer toute
une offre de master en particulier en
économie quantitative en finance
quantitative en date assaillent hans en
statistiques de façon vraiment
coordonner un peu toute cette offre qui
existe dans les différentes écoles et de
la proposer à nos propres étudiants en
complément de leur cycle ingénieur très
bien merci pierre miss coupe nous a pris
dans cette magnifique bibliothèque al
entzheim parité vous évoquiez le
logement mais justement nous allons
aller sur un immense chantier d'un ce
qui était un immense chantier puisqu'ils
ont travaillé à pied d'oeuvre pour que
ces logements soient soient ouverts pour
cette rentrée 2010 est je parle bien sûr
de serendipity
[Musique]
nous sommes au coeur de la résidence
étudiante cé rn 10 city qui se situe au
coeur du campus urbain et en particulier
sur le quartier du moulon cette
résidence étudiante se compose de huit
bâtiments dont sept ont déjà été livrés
pour la rentrée 2010 est et rassemble un
millier de logements étudiants pour les
étudiants de centrale supélec de
l'université paris sud est de los andes
paris saclay qui vont rejoindre
également le campus
cette résidence est emblématique des
ambitions de l'opéra paris saclay en
matière de logement étudiant ainsi que
de ses partenaires ses ambitions avait
été formulée dès 2012 dans la charte
habiter le campus qui définissait un peu
quelques grandes ambitions et notamment
la possibilité d'avoir différentes
typologies de logements étudiants donc à
la fois des studios classique mais
également des places en colocation et
qui met également l'accent sur
l'importance des locaux communs des
locaux de sociabilité dans les
résidences donc on retrouve avec la
résidence errani city et ses ambitions
et dernier élément qui était également
au coeur de les ambitions de le paix à
paris traquait des partenaires et l idée
que dans les résidences étudiantes se
mélangeaient les étudiants des
différentes composantes de du campus
paris saclay de l'université paris
saclay le positionnement de cette
résidence
elle se situe en face des trois
bâtiments ne centrale supélec dont les
deux nouveaux viennent d'être livré pour
la rentrée 2010 est également à
proximité de la nes paris-saclay de
l'iut d'orsay et du futur coeur de
quartier qui va être livré dans les deux
prochaines années et qui rassemblera des
logements familiaux mais également une
offre de commerces et des équipements
publics donc ici pour l'instant les
principaux programmes livrés sont à
vocation universitaire et de logement
étudiant
mais on est vraiment avec ce morceau
quartier avec cette première résidence à
l'interface d'un futur quartier de ville
et ça montre l'ambition de le pa2 et des
collectivités d'avoir un campus qui soit
ouvert sur la ville est vraiment
qui est des lieux de rencontres entre
les différents publics du site
il
[Musique]
jardin argenté est un espace public qui
s'inscrit dans un maillage globale des
espaces publics à l'échelle de
l'opération d'aménagement de la zac de
moulon il s'inscrit dans un système
global qui est composé de plusieurs
espaces publics qui vont être livrés
prochainement également le parc du
moulon le my la place du lieu de vie le
carré des sciences est également
l'ensemble des voiries et des espaces
publics et l'aménagement de ce jardin
est essentiel dans l'animation du campus
urbain de paris saclay il accompagne
l'ouverture de l'école centrale supélec
et offrira également un lieu d'agrément
confortable pour les habitants du
quartier donc ce jardin constitue un
lien naturel entre les étudiants de
l'école centrale et le reste du quartier
leur permettant ainsi d'avoir accès aux
transports en commun qui se
développeront d'abord avec les bus en
site propre et l'ensemble des mobilités
accessible puis à terme le métro qui se
situera plus au nord de ce jardin donc
ce jardin sera équipée de lieux qui
permettent donc de s'installer de lire
de jouer de s'allonger
du mobilier sera prévu pour mais
également de se promener au travers
d'une végétation qui a pu être conservé
cet hiver la plantation des arbres
viendra compléter l'aménagement paysager
du jardin et permettra aux futurs
habitants de profiter pleinement de ce
lieu
[Musique]
voilà c'est terminé pour cette première
émission première émission de rentrée
pour paris saclay tv d'ici là restez
informé sur notre site eps.fr merci de
votre fidélité et à très bientôt
[Musique]